mais d'abord retour sur ce weekend au
sein du parti LR avec Hugo Lemonnier
sourire et images de lune de miel entre
les ex rivaux du Congrès les
républicains
au menu ce midi
pissaladière farcis niçois et ralliement
d'Éric Ciotti je suis convaincu que
Emmanuel Macron et qu'elle pourra le
faire avec des idées
amende
au prix étonné beaucoup des personnes
qui me soutiennent j'entends que mes
idées soit représenté avec force une
unité d'autant plus fragile chez les
républicains qu'un autre candidat
lors de son Meetic d'entrée en campagne
je tend la main aux électeurs aux
sympathisants des républicains beaucoup
ont été représenté par mon ami Éric
Ciotti
[Applaudissements]
et parmi nous cet appel du pied du
candidat d'extrême droite à Éric Ciotti
accentue la pression sur Valérie
Pécresse forcé de réserver une place de
choix dans sa campagne au représentant
de la frange la plus radicale de sont
partis
et on analyse les 3 temps forts de ce
premier weekend de campagne
présidentielle les deux meeting
évidemment suis d'Éric Zemmour et de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais aussi le weekend
cette journée de lundi partie elle
[Musique]
est
vraiment lancer
une blague et qu'il était déjà candidat
ça compte une déclaration de candidature
un spot de campagne qui donne la
tonalité de la campagne le slogan qu'on
se donne aussi pour bannière comme
message principal et puis la capacité ou
non à faire ce premier meeting de
campagne et à part être crédible puisque
traverser une séquence je sais pas si si
c'était vrai mais il traverser une
séquence que en tout cas les
commentateurs je j'ai tout à fait
négative donc ça lui permet de passer à
autre chose et puis on parlera de des
autres aussi mais c'est vrai que c'était
un des éléments for the weekend à vous
prioritairement aller ce weekend
en tout cas
puisque on voit bien que pour Valérie
Pécresse finalement c'était pas
forcément celle qui était
dans une
dynamique extrêmement positives
passer jusqu'au jusqu'au deuxième tour
et maintenant les choses sérieuses
commencent avec ce foisonnement comme si
on était très proche de l'élection alors
qu'on en est encore à 4 mois mais c'est
vrai qu'il y avait une convergence des
dates qui font qu'on a pu avoir aussi
des analyses un peu transversale et
c'est ça qui est intéressant sur le fond
comme sur la forme il y a beaucoup de
choses à en dire Jean-Daniel le 8 vous
venez vous sortez là il est 18h06 donc
un sondage sur
l'impact de l'entrée en campagne de
Valérie Pécresse et alors ça donne ça
donne en
fait. Elle arrive à 14 pourcents est-ce
que le même niveau au quelle mesure et
bertrand pain de campagne
chez les républicains et puis là c'est
les intentions de vote tu règle une
capacité de progresser un peu prouver
qu'un point est à 14 % au même niveau
que on peut mesurer pour celles qui
subit cette situation là peut-être parce
qu'il a été un peu moins sur le devant
la scène se de son côté Marine Le Pen
qui reste un niveau confortable 18 %.
Intéressant c'est qu'on parle beaucoup
en fait d'un pays qui est Dépôt utiliser
qui est assez loin élections
présidentielles qui a tendance à
regarder ceci avec une distance c'est
vrai c'est faux c'est vrai parce
qu'aujourd'hui les intentions de vote
reflète un peu l'état d'esprit du pays
mais c'est faux parce qu'on voit bien
que dès qu'il y a des événements qui se
roule comme ça fait les cas ce weekend à
venir Le Mans réactivité de la part des
française et des Français qu'on
interroge et qu'ils vont dire tiens
voilà donc voilà comment je peux évoluer
dans mes représentations et dans mes
comportements électoraux potentiel alors
la cristallisation elle commence à peine
[Musique]
dans mon titre tout à l'heure la
captation des radicaux est d'accord avec
cette idée c'est un peu ce qui se jouer
ce weekend dans les différents lieux où
cette cette campagne c'est tout le monde
prendre la radicalité ça devient une
normalité c'est vrai qu'on voit bien
[Musique]
traditionnelle de la gauche et la droite
des républicains vers la droite extrême
droite
[Musique]
Éric Ciotti dans cette campagne qui a
commencé déjà fait remonter un peu les
enchères pas ce qui m'arrive est en tête
du premier tour du Congrès LR même si
c'était un quatre-quart
monte à 40 km le poids bien assister au
débat des candidats républicains qui est
quand même très très très très très à
droite
Marine Le Pen Éric Zemmour qui totalise
je prends le contrôle Jean-Daniel mes
deux quelques entre 30 et 35 %
voilà c'est une grande nouveauté en
France parce que c'est plutôt le score
quel effet le l'extrême droite au second
tour de la présidentielle jamais au
premier tour on n'est jamais arrivé à
son tour 2017 on n'était jamais arrivé à
des à des scores aussi et puis de
l'autre côté il y a Jean-Luc Mélenchon
occupé à la scène qu'il y a une égalité
radicalité programmatique bien connu son
programme
et
qui est à la fois par 2
d'avoir pardon le premier sondage après
ce weekend mais c'est toujours les
dynamiques c'est toujours les les
tendances long qui sont intéressantes à
analyser je préfère le rappeler aussi
prendre ses précautions
c'est aussi une campagne qui va faire
beaucoup de bruit du coup de pouce à
parler plus fort que le voisin et donc à
faire espèce de
perroquet
[Musique]
au sein de l'air et en même temps il
faut qu'elle élargie ça
maintenant qui rend les choses
intéressantes et qui peut en faire une
campagne extrêmement moderne pour pour
Valérie Pécresse si elle réussi à tenir
ce fils là de toute façon on t'enc
outsider qui est intéressant et on voit
bien c'est que vous vous pouvez
finalement avoir de bonnes surprises
pour voir si vous arrivez à cranter
rapidement avec cette incarnation de la
droite républicaine et manifestement ça
a l'air d'être un premier signal faible
rien n'est évidemment fait
avec ce caractère de Valérie Pécresse
qui est à la fois
une femme qui est dans le consensus
c'est une partie de d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'on lui reproche parfois à certaines à
certains égards mais c'est une femme de
consensus et en même temps quand on a la
curiosité d'aller regarder vraiment ce
qui se passe sur le régalien pour le
coup
compatible à un moment et surtout de
voir intégrer celle
qui me semble c'est que le
Constitutionnel en matière sur tous les
sujets régaliens qu'elle a porté pendant
pendant tout le projet et pendant le
congrès il faut le lire c'est
extrêmement
extrêmement dur ferme et donc je crois
que l'intérêt de Valérie Pécresse et on
verra si elle arrive à faire cette
synthèse c'est qu'elle a bien compris
aussi ce fameux quatre-quart au départ
donc là évidemment avec les sortie
médiatique poste dimanche soir on est un
peu focaliser sur Éric Ciotti le duel
entre les deux mais c'est plus large que
ça c'est-à-dire que pour qu'elle arrive
à consolider la famille de la droite
républicaine il faut qu'elle prenne
aussi ceux qui avaient réussi à avoir
des des des projets intéressants sur
Xavier Bertrand Philippe Juvin sur la
santé évidemment Michel Barnier
également il faut qu'elle fasse cette
synthèse
il y a derrière ça une attente de droite
très très ferme sur les sujets
d'autorité j'ai moi-même inventé il y a
quelques années le concept il y a
d'ailleurs repris fréquemment de droite
D complexe
avec
[Musique]
l'extrême droite
c'est 40 % deuxième tour dit qu'il est
un anti macroniste primaire et au
contraire totalement Zemmour compatible
Marine Le Pen qui me dis pas que des
bêtises la victoire de est
compatible des candidats qui était
désigné effectivement on ne voit pas
très bien quelle serait la différence
entre une Valérie Pécresse aux affaires
et un Édouard Philippe à Matignon ou un
Bruno Le Maire à Bercy donc on va bien
il y a un il y a un grand écart et elle
met le résultat quand même c'est le
choix possible si jamais Valérie
Pécresse n'était pas au deuxième tour le
choix possibles à faire précisément pour
le finaliste est Emmanuel Macron où
est-ce qu'on tombe Éric Zemmour et
Marine Le Pen on en a plus qu'une droite
D complexe et on a bien 3 tranches une
extrême droite D diaboliser avec Marine
Le Pen une extrême droite reviens
totalement décomplexé radicaliser avec
Éric Zemmour et on a par ailleurs 40 %
des sympathisants est l'air qui sont
précisément dans une boîte elle-même
républicaine elle-même extrême
regarder les scores de la dernière
présidentielle aujourd'hui on a 14
pourcents comme le disait Jean-Daniel à
l'instant 14 % Éric Zemmour et Valérie
Pécresse qui était à 14 % en décembre
2016 Emmanuel Macron et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon donc on voit bien que on peut
passer de 14 à 1 score suffisant pour
être deuxième tour et gagner la
présidentielle c'est intéressant de
faire ce comparatif à la fin il se passe
quoi en 2017 on a Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
termine à un score qui représente le
triple du score du candidat socialiste
18 % pour 6 aujourd'hui le rapport de
force entre une Valérie Pécresse même si
elle prend deux ou trois points dans la
Qataris Harris Interactive une Valérie
Pécresse qui est à peu près 3 fois moins
fort que l'extrême droite l'extrême
droite additionner et
Marine Le Pen et même une partie des
sympathisants LR donc on va voir si il
reste pour de vrai s'il reste pour le
vrai Sheller ou si il se laisse tenter
par l'appel de Zemmour parce que encore
une fois il peut y avoir une idée de
campagne créée par la désignation de
Valérie Pécresse mais il faut aussi
avoir une dynamique de campagne du côté
après la semaine passée la semaine
passée
et son premier meeting
immédiatement la cible des macroniste
démonstration éléments de langage avec
Amélie de Montchalin Christophe Castaner
et Bruno Le Maire
le projet de
le frappe c'est un projet de recyclage
pour le 20e siècle
21e siècle que
les idées sont recyclés et que les
Français en ont pas voulu avec François
Fillon pas pourquoi il en voudrait plus
vraiment très François Fillon
François Fillon bon c'est un peu les
éléments de langage
depuis 10 ans
en 2012
j'ai perdu à cause de la mauvaise image
de Nicolas Sarkozy et une fois volet de
plus en 2017 à cause de faire de
François Fillon du coup on n'a jamais
fait son agenda mento elle n'a jamais
travaillé sur le fond en disant ah ben
voilà une autre vision de la société
qu'est-ce qu'on peut proposer
deux fois mon programme et de fois de
fois on s'est fait voler l'élection
quand vous regardez la campagne sur quoi
sur l'autorité la belle affaire c'est
nouveau ça l'autorité alors maintenant
c'est pas nouveau sur le travail ou la
belle affaire déjà Nicolas Sarkozy en
2007 faisait campagne sur le travail est
sur l'autorité les territoires
classiques aussi du centre droit il y a
rien de nouveau il y a rien de nouveau
sur je vous donnez des exemples de la
société sur le statut salariale
aujourd'hui surtout ce qu' il y a
l'impression c'est là où la critique de
veau de mer mais on n'a pas tout à fait
tort sur qu'est-ce que la droite a comme
diagnostic de la société autre que il
faut être de plus en plus dur avec le
crime ce qui est normal pour la droite
et de plus en plus ferme avec les
immigrés c'est aussi un discours
discours aujourd'hui je le vois je vois
pas ce qu'il y a eu parce que je pense
qu'il y a pas eu ce travail après on a
pas de tirer les leçons de l'échec à
droite on les a juste de coller sur deux
personnes aller conduire votre Simpson
qui il est aussi là pour fournir des
idées pas seulement la droite mais
notamment à la droite donc comment vous
réagissez à la droite
je vous trouve un peu sévère
c'est-à-dire que je prendrai votre votre
remarque plus par rapport à l'organisme
et par rapport aux parties
je ferai une petite distinction quand
même avec les différents candidats qui
ont eu des équipes programmatique et et
vous avez des idées qui sont ressortis
et qui ont permis d'ailleurs d'avoir
cette qualité qui n'était pas gagné
d'avance quand même remettons nous il y
a quelques mois personne ne parlait sur
une séquence qui arrive à son terme
jusqu'à dimanche soir avec cette tenue
de débat à la fois sur le fond en
revanche ce qui est vrai c'est que pour
gagner une une présidentielle
souvent alors mais on dit souvent qu'il
faut quand même être celui qui arrive à
imposer les thématiques donc ce qui sera
intéressant à mon sens ce sera notamment
à partir du mois de janvier de voir si
on arrive à remettre dans le débat
public bien sur les question d'autorité
sur lesquels ce sont des questions de
droite mais ils sont abordés déjà avec
un prisme un peu différent je crois que
il y a
aujourd'hui
de personnalité au sein je vois par
exemple avec
la société civile
et il y a eu cette ouverture ça
a été capable
et de et de prendre en compte un certain
nombre de de signaux pour les intégrer
parce que il y a eu une différence
d'approche par rapport à la façon dont
ton je crois on abordait ces questions
même chose on verra alors
janvier je pense que la question du
pouvoir d'achat et une question qui est
absolument fondamental le rapport au
travail vous le dit mais il va falloir
prendre la question de la compétitivité
de la France et je pense qu'un des
marqueurs très fort justement notamment
par rapport à l'exécutif par rapport au
gouvernement c'est la question de
l'ordre dans les contes et ça c'est une
thématique ça c'est pas nouveau mais
vous avez une grande différence
aujourd'hui c'est comme ça avec la
transition écologique voilà ce sont des
sujets que les jeunes s'intéresse à ce
scrutin on ne peut pas faire l'économie
d'une approche totalement audacieuse sur
les quais de de de croissance avec
l'économie croissance ou pas on pourrait
avoir
pour ma part croissance
weekend
[Musique]
et que
ça joue quand même
sur Facebook et autres c'est pas vrai
si on continue à se diffuser en totalité
avec qui puisait une diffusion pas une
réalisation qui dépend entièrement
des équipes de campagne à donc ils vont
choisir les angles la manière dont se
mettre un film et les
hommes qui ont été tués sur les
spectateurs sur les
politiques toutes les enquêtes que le
fait que l'on voit du monde le fait
qu'on voit des militants le fait qu'on
voit ou qu'on entende on va gagner et
qu'il sorte de de de de de de sentiments
positifs joue et puis on joue au jeu
également le responsable politique et
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs un peu les
premiers retours qu'on a eu à l'étude
par exemple de la prise de parole hier
d'Éric Zemmour comme quelqu'un par le
passé concernant Jean-Luc Mélenchon on
joue j'ai un peu la personne en se
disant est-ce qu'elle est capable de
pouvoir se redresser à d'Émilie quand
est-ce qu'ils arrivent à faire passer
ses messages est-ce qu'il a cette
capacité à pouvoir montrer une forme de
conviction et que ça joue très fortement
Jean-Luc Mélenchon avec un construit sa
légitimité
2007 et en 2012 et surtout en 2017
autour des meetings et dans cette
capacité oratoire qu'elle était reconnu
et qui faisait au moins il maîtrise le
sujet et donc on va considérer qu'il a
une légitimité à pouvoir prendre la
parole et donc des atouts pour pouvoir
être le chef ou en tout cas le
représentant de l'État pour pour ce qui
était chez plus de voter pour lui
vous êtes intéressé à la façon dont Éric
Zemmour a choisi ces cibles en quelque
chose parce que on sait bien qu'on peut
se finit en positif ou en négatif parce
que je peux dire ce que je suis que je
ne suis pas ce que je veux et ce que je
ne veux pas et que la matière de
discours d'hier nous dit beaucoup
d'avoir ce ils au pluriel ne sont ils au
pluriel farielle parce qu'il est
vraiment pas pour l'écriture inclusive
il a appelé mais ils se sont les
politiques parfois ce sont ses pouvoirs
et tout ce qu'il englobe d'autrefois sur
les jours la gauche
mais le plus souvent c'est
comme quand il dit
il l'avait souci mais sous-estimer il
pensait même sans être débarrassé il
avait tort ou encore ils veulent nous
interdire des fois ils veulent me rendre
inéligible ils veulent voulais la
démocratie vous voulez les donations va
bien cette idée de désignation d'un
ennemi commun dans un adversaire commun
et qui est parfois une coalition ça te
fera faire ma série sentent mes
adversaires de maman politique les
journalistes bonne-maman sociale et les
djihadistes veulent ma mort tu cours
comme s'il y avait une espèce de
synthèse de tous les anti Zemmour qui
chercherait à le faire taire aussi on va
bien double effet rechercher c'est eux
et nous c'est de la victimisation et la
désignation se développer une sorte de
mentalité d'assiéger pour fédérer les
troupes et c'est de faire un réflexe
alors de résistance des petits loups de
combat et puis aussi ce qui est l'homme
qui n'a rien perdu de son venin de
polémiste Valérie Pécresse elle rappelle
sans cesse sur l'entrée politique Chirac
elle crois sur parole elle a géré comme
son mentor est le promettre à tous et ne
tiendra rien mais le pire c'est lui qui
a pris toutes les flèches et de façon la
plus c'est évidemment le président de la
République écouter
la personne Emmanuel Macron ne nous
intéresse pas parce qu'elle est
fondamentalement inintéressante
[Musique]
la pensée d'Emmanuel Macron
il n'est personne un peu plus loin dans
son discours il dit la France a eu le
néant et elle est tombé dedans nous
laissons sa vitrine ce mannequin de
plastique cette automatique hier dans un
labyrinthe des miroirs ce masque son
visage qui définir le pourquoi je vous
dis ça parce que en fait il y a une
forme d'anéantissement de la personne du
Président il n'est rien il n'y a
personne c'est le néant il y a une forme
de c'est un anéantissement symbolique
une femme de déshumanisation c'est un
masque son visage c'est un automate
c'est un mannequin de plastique un peu
comme les mannequins à l'effigie de
Macron qui sont parfois secouer dans les
manifs bien le président République au
jury les mots les plus un être humain
mets un mannequin un robot donc on est
vraiment dans une attaque je rentre j'ai
rarement été aussi violent
Marine Le Pen
qui sait on sait jamais il vaut mieux
pas insulter l'avenir mais c'est aussi
comme s'il cherchait à la faire oublier
à l'effacer parce que ce qu'on ne sommes
pas un existe pas il y a deux reprises
écouter la façon dont tu parles du
mouvement politique de Marine Le Pen
[Musique]
Front national
comme si il fallait effacer des données
une façon de dire que s'il ne font plus
grand cas de la fille il s'inscrit
orange dans les pas du père et là on
voit bien que le signal il est appuyé et
je voudrais qu'on qu'on analyse merci
Mathieu la hauteur de la question de la
violence c'est vrai que vous parliez de
du fait que les les
équipes politique avec la main sur les
images qu'elle diffuse et pendant
[Musique]
ce meeting il a été marqué
ce sont celles qui ont filmé
ça
déclenche l'action de certains
spectateurs
des violences inadmissible mets la
provocation peut inciter à ce qu'a dit
le président du Sénat
que vous êtes d'accord avec cette phrase
de
ce weekend et à très intéressante en
dans le pays le premier chef Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et également un peu Marine Le
Pen et en tout cas de la Fondation
Jean-Jaurès
récemment et
c'est précisément
les deux ce weekend je rejoins
exactement à l'instant il y a
dans le discours d'Éric Zemmour qu'on ne
retrouve plus aujourd'hui chez Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
[Musique]
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qualité et même dans une radicalité
populiste un populisme de gauche il y a
50 qui l'a mise en sourdine aujourd'hui
pour parti à l'inverse Éric Zemmour dans
ce meeting dans ce discours de dimanche
à lui-même fait évoluer sa syntaxe et en
particulier la sémantique la rhétorique
du il m'a tu me crois si tu avais raison
d'insister là-dessus c'est quelque chose
qui bouge et donc la radicalité en
politique ou même la violence en
politique quelques Éric Zemmour Paul un
carnet à travers ses propos ça produit
de la violence alors il est logique il y
a une part de responsabilité de logique
de la violence dans ses propos de
logique quand même
le candidat à l'élection présidentielle
aujourd'hui officiel qui a déjà été
quand même
alors
est-ce que c'est une provocation quand
même Alexia Germont de la part de
racisme
[Musique]
sémantique qui est particulièrement
monter crescendo ces derniers temps les
derniers déplacement d'Éric Zemmour ne
se sont pas bien passé c'est un acte
fort de se rendre dans un meeting
d'opposants voilà c'est je ne sais pas
si c'est une provocation en tout cas la
violence ne dois absolument pas
évidemment être présente je trouve que
ce sont des images qui font extrêmement
mal à la à la démocratie est de la même
façon parce qu'on a pas mentionné mais
moi je suis aussi choquée de la façon
dont Éric Zemmour lorsqu'il se rend sur
scène a été non pas prise à partie mais
il a été agressé est-ce qu'il fait une
différence je trouve dans 7
façon dont c'est traité c'est que
traditionnellement vous avez des
services de sécurité qui sont capables
justement d'éviter les dérapages et là
on se rend compte que le service de
sécurité n'a pas été capable d'éviter
les scènes de violence entre militants
comme celle-là
[Musique]
complètement
tout le monde et
qui
se bat contre
des critiques quoi déstabiliser le
pouvoir en fait non c'est moyen ça m'est
égal mais en fait tout ce qui s'est
passé autour de Villepinte où on sait
qu'il y a des personnes qui sont
un peu plus violente encore intervenu là
pour le coup avec la volonté d'en
découdre avec soin les forces de l'ordre
soit éventuellement le service d'ordre
ou des personnes qui a des produits
dérivés mon oncle
mélange un petit peu et quand on a une
opinion qui est forgé et les images
et le
système
[Musique]
qu'on le veuille ou non l'image d'Éric
Zemmour a une forme de désordre voir de
chaos voir de violence et ça parce que
ce qu'il faut dans les meetings
retransmis Jean-Daniel m'a parlé tout à
l'heure c'est que c'est devenu les
programmes télévisés vous avez raison
vous avez prévu les mots ont été vu par
près de
travailler les deux,
on
est en 2017
de gens qui n'auraient pas voter pour
moi qui ne voudrais pas moi et puis en
plus d'image personnel à corriger parce
que la radicalité c'est lui il a plutôt
tendance à maintenant essaie de montrer
qu'il peut il peut être sûr de choses
surtout depuis l'image est partie de la
perquisition de la même la dégagés lors
de la nuit on sait on sait aujourd'hui
je finance un peu il y a des différentes
dans une campagne électorale il se
trouve que à partir du moment où Éric
Zemmour se déclarer officiellement
candidat cette semaine et donc tu
connais son premier meeting de campagne
ce dimanche il n'en n'est pas encore au
stade
de présenter un programme
il a encore une fois un message
et
en fait
elle et
moi on a besoin de
plus en plus
et
je sais pas trop
peut-être même plus capter ailleurs au
sein de l'échiquier politique si par
exemple un Jean-Luc Mélenchon qu' il y a
5 ans était dans une forme de radicalité
et encore une fois de nouveautés ça
n'était que sa deuxième et candidature à
l'élection présidentielle
peut-être qu'on le sens un peu plus
fatigué ou en tout cas moi c'est un
sentiment que j'ai eu en assistant en
suivant
[Musique]
il a travaillé utilisation du compteur
la façon alors là on n'a pas mis le son
mais la façon de placer sa voix aussi
est-ce que vous diriez qui a fait ça
hier
et
puis
je crois
concernant Éric Zemmour en fait il est
bon quand il est seul face à son micro
pendant 2 minutes 2 minutes pour ce
n'est pas assez tu es capable de pouvoir
être bon dans le cas d'un débat il a eu
des moments qu'on était plus ou moins
fort au moment de ça après campagne il y
avait vraiment le grand et encore une
fois j'assiste là-dessus tout ce qui
peut être la communication non verbale
tout ce qui peut être en fait les
dimensions qui veut des dimensions de
posture d'attitude capacité à porter sa
voix joue très profondément dans la
construction d'un responsable politique
et on sait à quel point les Français se
projette en se disant ouh là cet
exercice est difficile il arrive à le
faire donc ça veut dire qu'on arrive à
l'image il est dans des situations qui
sont potentiellement inimaginable où il
aurait la capacité à pouvoir réagir à
des situations qui sont pas forcément le
temps anticipable
que je suis
et c'est vrai que transmission
émotions en patine alors on est moins
sur le registre empathique sur le fond
évidemment mais il faut être capable de
d'être en symbiose avec les personnes
qui sont en face de vous tous à sa main
à l'incarnation et là où il a je crois
bien réussi effectivement l'exercice
formelle c'est qu'il est arrivé à mettre
de la musique du silence à certains
moments de savoir prendre jouer avec la
salle exactement donc il avait en fait
suffisamment les fondamentaux acquis
pour se permettre de la liberté et c'est
là tu ou un travail considérable a été
fait par rapport à la au premier
discours qui avait été catastrophique
lors du congrès avec Marion Maréchal-Le
Pen Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour terminer ce
premier des balles quand il y a de la
France insoumise qui a fustigé le
capitalisme l'argent qui corrompt tu es
aussi parler de ça France en opposition
à celle de l'extrême droite écouter
[Musique]
pour lui redonner du course à l'or
[Applaudissements]
Mathieu c'est un grand meeting de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
et
d'ailleurs
il est dans l'exercice est
en tout cas
le problème de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
il est il est il arrive quand même
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
et
et et
il aurait pu être le principal opposants
à Emmanuel Macron contest Ancenis Beral
pour partie Salines autoritaire en
particulier dans la gestion des
mouvements sociaux il n'a jamais réussi
à incarner cela il a des vices et des
l'ambiguïté qui a été la sienne lors de
la précédente élections présidentielles
l'entre-deux-tours les fameuses entre
deux tours et puis il a surtout dévisser
avec effectivement la gestion de ses
mises encore mise en cause judiciaire
pardon et et voilà et depuis il n'a
cessé de dévisser et je parle tu
contrôles de Jean-Daniel il y a deux
dimensions il y a l'équation personnel
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et il y a par
ailleurs en tout cas dans dans les
enquêtes que nous avons mené à la
Fondation Jean-Jaurès la question aussi
de la la désaffiliation de la sympathie
partisane ce n'est pas seulement
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui paie ses excès
c'est outrant c'est maladresse voir ses
fautes c'est la France insoumise qui
parvient moins qu'il y a 5 ans à capter
une partie de lectorat de droite alors
ça sert Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui est
aujourd'hui le leader qui se maintient
le mieux à la gauche de l'échiquier
politique mais on voit que tu as au
stade en tout cas la dynamique c'est pas
exactement de son côté
est-ce que il y a un aspect
générationnel dans les sympathisants de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon un peu plus jeune que
[Musique]
toi
aujourd'hui
location un peu émancipatrice porté par
la petite donc ils vont être les porter
ou les ou les destinataires c'est un des
points qui qui revient avec Mélenchon
après Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est le
mouvement est-ce qu'elle était indiqué
tout à l'heure par Mathieu souper avec
tout à fait vrai qu'on a une belle
aujourd'hui de la proximité à l'égard de
la France insoumise mais vu que
l'appréciation de Jean-Luc Mélenchon a
eu tendance à BC notamment du fait de la
magie facile à gérer les perquisition
qui sont déroulés au siège de la France
insoumise sur la totalité du moment
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
quand on analyse bien le discours de
Mélenchon il cherche plus à se mettre en
retrait et à mettre en avant une
dimension collective comme il ne l'a
jamais fait le parlementaire qui
construit et également son programme
politique en disant moi je ne suis en
gros que le vecteur mais je suis pas
l'acteur centrale voter pour le
programme
personnellement merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce que c' est
le titre de votre livre écris avec
Damien Fleurot 2022 La Flambée populiste
aux éditions
[Musique]